hey this is Shaquille O'Neal and this is
the famous Shack cam here we are NBA
All-Star Game
2023. Chris Tucker this is the dunk cam
who you got in the dunk contest you know
I got a uh who have you got first of all
I told you to meet me in the back of the
Arena
I don't know man
you know it
Mr shot Duncan what you got Ducktown
yeah I don't really know who's in it to
be honest okay
yeah
who you got the dunk contest oh
I got Mac McClung
no Kenny Martin Jr okay all right okay
hey hey hold on hold on America this guy
right here always tried to throw me out
of the finals this dude right here this
dude right here what's up brother his
camera's improved since 2000 when he had
the camp Court doing this we're missing
his name
slice who you got the dunk contest boy
yeah who you got all right
this is the famous I apologies
only a Knicks going to win Jericho
series
Spike Lee what's happening
the Duncan what you got hello Miss Union
who you got in the dunk on this I'm
doing good who you got in the dunk on
this
well y'all got the dunk contest
okay
thank you I won't bother you no more
tonight
hello
[Laughter]
how are you and I say yes I am a blogger
I'm a blogger now
who y'all got in the dunk contest
yeah me
[Applause]
done
thank you
oh
this kid right here got some hops Murphy
no no this kid right here got some help
[Music]
[Applause]
stay right there this is where you steal
the show no nobody knows your name make
them remember your name and don't miss a
dunk all right good luck brother all
right big fan of yours
here we go the first dunk
[Music]
okay
see
that he wants to Crown and come on come
on
[Applause]
[Music]
impressive
I like that one
that was nice
anyway what you think flash what you
think Fletch
yeah
what you think what you think of that
dump huh what you think of that dog
okay okay
at least he made it on the first attempt
that's all I care about right that's it
that's it besides that's all I can say
it again say it again
[Applause]
who you like dude that's that Shack hey
what's that Shaq came that thing beastly
the shot cabin that we had during Golden
State during the bench call today yeah
okay I like that dump because he made it
on the first attempt yes that's what
I've been saying this first attempt you
get all the love you need let's let's
preserve the dunk contest with this man
right over there started Dr J he started
it let's preserve it all right here we
go
[Music]
[Applause]
representing the Big Fellas here we go
at least he made it he made it he made
it super specialist but he made it he
wasn't super special but he made it on
the first time
[Music]
what you think
what you think Savage
[Music]
watch out crane
all right come on come on
move crane
[Music]
oh
you got it let's go KJ
come on KJ
[Applause]
okay okay okay
be back hey Scott he got to make it on
the first attempt
got to make it on the first attempt
what
no way
move that dick move that damn crane
excuse me
[Applause]
what I tell you
what I tell you he hungry
foreign
[Applause]
what you think
oh
what is this
oh what is this
[Music]
[Applause]
what is this
[Music]
experience
[Applause]
[Music]
say it again
[Applause]
a ball it's great I don't know
[Music]
oh [__]
good job big dog
I can't do it
a lot of people over here can't do that
what kind of ball is that rubber
no consistency
yeah bounce
[Music]
they're trying to move us back they
don't want us to participate in the
shack dunk cam contest
oh there's a drone
whatever though
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
what I like about this year's contest
they're making it on the first attempt
the crowd is enjoying it I love that
that was nice that was nice
all right
look at the replay
[Applause]
say it again
what you think what you think for sure
you like it he did like three done
brought it down
like a 45 that's good right there
oh
big man kind of swollen
God damn it slow
no way
no way I
what you think what you think CJ
[Music]
what are you gonna do take a picture
don't worry about him Joshua with me
you gonna do big dog
[Music]
I'm not gonna let you say that on the
air
no it's good I got you
what's in there wait hold on
don't say nothing just make a face
I don't know I don't know about that one
yeah I could have
went up
what's up Drew get up in there who you
like so far in the dunk contest I like
mac McClung man you do yeah you sure hey
man
I know man
what's good
excuse me sexy man
[Applause]
whoa
what was that
what was that I don't know
yo what was that what'd he do
it
damn
that's crazy
I do that ain't even an NBA gonna win
that bank
[Music]
oh my God
[Applause]
[Music]
come on Mac don't miss
you don't miss Mac
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
Michael Michael I got that
okay
he double pumped it I think so what you
think there's a I don't know you better
come with something super move that damn
train
[Music]
I think Matt wasn't though and not only
that I think in the last round you got
to show off however the dunk contest is
back up it's not going down but it's
back up here you go
in it compete compete Zion come on
Dade City I don't know what that means
foreign
[Applause]